make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are finally getting back into
the Justice Doom war by Scott Snyder we
are getting into part two part DOS and
this is gonna be kind of a big one here
right there's a lot going on but as a
bit of a refresher for people who are
unfamiliar right because it took us a
little while to kind of get back into
this what do you basically have here the
kind of big overarching thing is the
return of Perpetua and the reason why we
say the return is because Perpetua was
the one who created the multiverse right
this at least this particular multiverse
in DC Comics and the idea was that she
was essentially not really governed by
so much as ruled over or assisted by
these kind of apex predator soldiers now
eventually she was defeated by the
combined forces of the monitor the
anti-monitor
and the forger of worlds and so
following her defeat and her
imprisonment within the source wall it
then turned to the monitor the
anti-monitor in the forger of worlds to
begin creating kind of like a new
multiverse that basically you know ended
up in its current form as it exists now
and of course included things like you
know Infinite Crisis Final Crisis crisis
on Infinite Earths different things like
that but the idea was that perpetual has
basically been released by by Lex Luthor
and Lex Luthor is kind of reverted back
into one of her apex predators right now
the way this played out was originally
these Predators were ultimately split
but one one part of them kind of became
humans the other part became martians
and so with lex luthor absorbing martian
manhunter that's how we kind of referred
it back into this sort of apex version
of a character for these kind of
soldiers that were used by Perpetua in
order to rule the unit of rule of
multiverse and her her vision of the
multiverse is a dark place right it's a
very dark and very harsh environment and
so in order to keep this this victory
from happening by the Legion of Doom
what is it up happening is that the
Justice League was really split into two
parts one part basically went into the
past the other part went into the
present and then another part basically
stayed into a state in the present day
but the idea is that they're essentially
traveling throughout the entire time
stream to find these these artifacts
these pieces of the totality which can
be assembled and be used which is their
only real chance of defeating Perpetua
because of the fact that it has so much
incredible power and so the the version
of the Justice League that went into the
past including the flash Green Lantern
the Jon Stewart and so on ended up
running into the Justice Society of
America and that's where this picks up
now here's the important thing to
understand here and here's kind of the
interesting thing about this is a lot of
this is being viewed by brainy
by brainiacs basically kind of getting
along the path of bottling up cities
different things like that but we don't
really know
exactly what his role is in all this and
so far as you know outside of the part
of the Legion of Doom and bottling of
worlds and ensuring that justice Lee
can't find the the totality and the
various aspects of the timestream
it basically leads to like the JSA and
in this version the Justice League
encounter each other but they've never
met and they don't know who the other is
and this is kind of an important thing
right because one part of this really
kind of leads into the idea of Doomsday
Clock which is to say the fact that ten
years from these heroes Matan memories
were basically missing but the other
part of this is that technically the JSA
doesn't exist in DC and the reason why
is because if you guys remember from
Doomsday Clock the JSA was formed by
Green Lantern Alan Scott but because of
the fact that dr. Manhattan had
basically intervened and Alan Scott died
before he could attain his Green Lantern
the JSA was never formed and so there
was no indication that characters like
Jay Garrick or any of those guys ever
existed now Doomsday Clock will likely
rectify all of that when the final issue
comes out but as it stands at the moment
Barry does not know who Jay Garrick is
and Jay Garrick does not know who
various and this is a particularly
interesting continuity error considering
the fact that very Allen during the
events of the button knew who Jay
Garrick was right so that's why things
are kind of finicky here that's why
things are kind of funny it's a little
strange in terms of how it all comes
together this is likely just a massive
continuity error by DC but the cool
thing about this is that for people who
were fans of the JSA you get to see them
in spectacular fashion right you get to
see Jay Garrick you get to see Alan
Scott really being the kind of heroes
that they were now in terms of of why
they're in this particular point in time
either in this era we don't know
explicitly when this time here takes
place we simply just know that it's in
the past but before we get into that
what we're gonna do is we're gonna
switch over to command II basically the
the last human being alive on earth in
this future where you have Batman
Superman Wonder Woman and so on and
animals have really kind of risen up now
of course we covered how all this
transpired in the first video so you're
welcome to go check that out to kind of
get the origin of how this future ended
up the way that it was but of course
they're immediately set upon by all
these members of these Brainiac robots
and so on and so forth these kind of
police force or what-have-you but
essentially what you end up getting here
is basically them tracking down and
trying to locate the Hall of Justice
and it's kind of a cool little thing
here because once they're able to locate
that locate the Hall of Justice itself
and once you're able to kind of initiate
their plan ultimately it allows them to
actually leave this universe and start
traveling to the other universes that
Brainiac has at his disposal and the
reason why is because the totality could
be in any
one of those and that's what really
makes a situation so hairy is because
what they're looking for is essentially
a needle in a stack of needles right I
mean they they literally have to go
through every single one of these
universes that that Brainiac has and try
to find the totality in each one right
so it's gonna be kind of a kind of a
crazy thing because totality is only in
one of them right and that's where
things kind of get crazy and kind of get
bonkers is because ultimately they have
to use this kind of beacon of source to
try to locate it would it be insanely
difficult to find now of course at the
same time you've got the present-day
Justice League which is to say the
forger of worlds and the monitor
alongside a hot grill and so on who
basically go into bleed space right
because their idea is to locate the
anti-monitor now those guys who are
familiar with bleed space the bleed
itself in DC is essentially the space
between universes right so it's like if
I took a whole bunch of golf balls and I
put them in a sink of water all that
water represents the bleed right the
space between the different universes
and each one of those golf balls is a
universe itself right so that's really
all that is now normally you're talking
about an extremely dangerous place to
try to navigate through and I mean you
can't take any any kind of
technologically advanced vessel from
from DC or from the main DC universe and
just fly into bleep space and be fine it
would probably tear it to pieces right
that's a reason why you have the the
multiversal Justice League for example
which uses a specialized ship in order
to do it and this particular vessel has
been retrofitted by the forger of worlds
and the monitor in order to try to try
to maintain and sustain itself while
they're traveling through the bleed but
there's no guarantee but the cool thing
about this this is kind of kind of an
interesting takeaway from this is that
what you end up getting is basically
this this kind of recollection or at
least as this instance whereby when
Superman and his forces travel from one
of the universes of Brainiac into
another they essentially end up
encountering a group this that really
refers to themselves as the Justice
League in a now Justice Legion a also
stands for Justice Legion Alpha and long
time DC fans will immediately recognize
this group because this is the version
of the Justice League from DC 1 million
and that's kind of the dangerous thing
about this because what it shows is that
as part of the Legion part of the Legion
of Doom from Lex Luthor what Brainiac
has been doing is running all throughout
the timestream and basically capturing
all these different universes or all
these little portions of a universe from
all throughout the time stream right
from the very very distant past all the
way up to the distant future and so
that's what makes things so crazy and
that's why they have to jump from one
container basically to the next trying
to find the totality where where every
be among all these different universes
it's an insane kind of goal to have to
achieve but the Justice League and alpha
is an exceedingly powerful team right
because in a DC 1 million landscape the
Justice League really evolved beyond its
role of being a protector of the world
and instead it evolved out to become a
protector of the galaxy and so justice
Legion alpha had this base of operations
on Jupiter and they're charged with
protecting the solar system right so
basically what you're getting here is
the the DC 1 million team which is kind
of cool to see them return here at the
same time and I don't know how I really
feel about this
we basically end up finding out that the
this this particular group of the
Justice Society of America of course is
operating in 1945 during World War 2 and
the Legion of Doom forces who have made
their way into the past really kind of
try to cut off the superhero team are
basically piloting Japanese planes in
order to attack Pearl Harbor which is
kind of a it's kind of a crappy thing to
do I think kind of weird kind of strange
but the reason why you had the JSA
during 1945 is because when you had the
JSA originally in DC they were basically
like an earth 1 and alternate reality
team right I mean originally they were
World War 2 characters but when DC
created the multiverse they basically
said okay so essentially like all the
superheroes or all I guess the version
of the Justice League that Jay Garrick
was a part I was on earth too and this
new Justice League is on earth one
that's basically it when you got to
crisis on Infinite Earths the entire
multiverse was wiped away and the JSA
went with it right because there was no
alternate reality there would be no
basis for the JSA to exist but it did
have a huge fan base and so what DC did
is they came back with the
reintroduction of the JSA and what they
said was that the JSA fought during
World War two they were basically
superheroes who existed her in the 1940s
and 1950s and so by the time Superman
rose to promise by the time Clark Kent
moved to Metropolis and became Superman
by the time that Bruce Wayne's parents
were murdered he went and trained and
then came back to Gotham and became
Batman by the time all these modern era
superheroes rose to prominence the JSA
had been retired and so when when you
got to the events before the new 52 in
2011 the JSA was basically a bunch of
retired superheroes who came out of
retirement and back into active
superheroing again and that's how you
got those teams unified together it's
why you see them here during World War
Two this was really kind of a kind of a
bookend way I think for Scott Snyder to
kind of bring the JSA back and say well
this is probably how they're gonna
return yes the way there
during World War two and was likely
going on here during Doomsday Clock
especially when we saw by Johnny Thunder
and characters like that who were
originally part of the JSA as their
minds were white they don't know who
they are characters like Jay Garrick
were removed and filled into the Speed
Force and all the other members of the
JSA don't know who they are like Alan
Scott's dead Johnny Thunder is stuck in
an insane asylum everybody thinks he's
crazy when he's saying that like he's
got crazy powers and so on and so forth
Jay Garrick some the Speed Force and any
other members of the JSA had likely had
their memories wiped by Manhattan which
is why they're not active anymore right
so I mean there's there's all kinds of
little things that can go into it little
tidbits here and there they can really
kind of clear all this up but what it
does is it basically shows it's kind of
going into this this tale a little bit
here it shows us that essentially
Aquaman is working on behalf of the
anti-monitor that during the the story
where Aquaman was supposed to have died
the drowned earth event where Aquaman
was supposed to have been removed and
killed off the what the anti-monitor did
was essentially save him and then turn
him into a henchman for himself now the
reason why that's the case actually
becomes prominent here in a minute and
the reason why and this is particularly
important is because there's a common
conversation that takes place between
Wonder Woman and commanding basically
what is it going on here is that in this
future that's DC 1 million future that
the Justice League temporarily faces off
against the Justice League in a it's not
a great big huge knock-down drag-out
fight instead they're basically fighting
these kind of year these these other
forces out there can ultimately end up
defeating them but there's this
conversation of Wonder Woman has in the
sense that commodity comes from an age
when war is all they really know we're
like war is what brought the downfall of
society but the world that he lives in
is harsh and it's really kind of not
really every man for himself so much is
survived by whatever means you can and
so as a result that we're commanded
comes from discipline from is from a
future where you do have little
civilizations there in little pockets of
groups and things like that where people
do work together for the most part he's
used to a very harsh environment and so
when he looks back on the recollection
or at least on these these stories of
old right you know the world being funds
into war and things like that his
perception of the past is that all
humanity did was engage in war and so
when he met the Justice League and they
basically showed him that hey it's not
all just about warfare there's things
like compassion things like hope and
that's what warfare is predicated on we
fight these fights because we want to
ensure that people who are innocent
don't really end up getting caught in
these things but also because by
defeating these bad guys there's hope
for a better tomorrow it really kind of
seems to instill in the idea of Kimani
to simply not just run
this idea that he's really kind of the
only hope they have insofar as he'll do
what needs to be done in order to help
try to save the day and so ultimately
what is up happening is one of the
members of the Justice League is housing
their totality itself and so because of
the fact that the intention once
Brainiac one-million reveals himself
where the intention is to use this power
to essentially take out the Justice
League in as well as the Justice League
of America incapacitate them most likely
forced them into subservience by turning
them into as his soldiers or what have
you but this mortality is taken by
Wonder Woman and given to Kamandi and
then basically Kamandi is sent out in
order to ensure the survival of the
totality that's exceedingly important
what we end up doing is jumping back to
the past and probably one of the coolest
things because where this whole battle
is raging during a during World War two
you know with regards to the attack on
Pearl Harbor all these soldiers that
when the USS Arizona is hit by a torpedo
and and sunk were under normal
circumstances and in real world history
a litany of soldiers died during that
that whole that whole scenario instead
aquaman comes to the rescue with a
Kraken and there's one of the coolest
things right to see him just like pop up
with this enormous Kraken but it's kind
of a funny theme because what he does is
he tells them like look I get you guys
are here to get the totality and that's
cool and everything but you can't
succeed right here there's no way you
guys can win here it's not really
possible as it was kind of a funny thing
here because when when you get this
whole thing unfolding it's like okay so
like all fingers and all scenarios are
pointing to the idea that what the
Justice League is doing is that while
they're trying their best there's
nothing they really can do there's
nothing they can do to win because the
power of Perpetua is growing every
second of every day and it's getting to
the point where it's basically
uncontainable right where it where it
can't be stopped
and so what you end up having is
Perpetua who basically travels with like
Lex Luthor directly to the very edge of
all things in existence and ultimately
meets with the anti-monitor and the
question is which side does the
anti-monitor choose and it's kind of a
cool thing here because you would look
at the anti-monitor
as a character an you would say okay so
it's always been a villain right the
anti-monitor has led to the destruction
of the multiverse and the first crisis
on Infinite Earths event and then while
it didn't really reappear in the
traditional sense until Darkseid war as
far as it actually being a being that
exists out there the events of Darkseid
war the events that led up to it like
forever evil saw and saw the
anti-monitor traveling from one universe
to the next and continuing to wipe it
out right so he's always kind of been
this force of nature almost Galactus to
a degree but with a little more hint
evil in it but when you have a scenario
unfold ultimately the anti-monitor in
subsiding with the forger of worlds the
monitor and Earth's superheroes and so
what this shows is that essentially
everybody has it out for perpetual right
like everybody's against perpetuate here
but it's kind of a cool scenario because
the way the Scots matter plays this out
is okay but like they can't really win
anyway and it doesn't really even matter
and this is really kind of what it kind
of comes to a head when you end up
having the forger of worlds who goes to
attack Perpetua and nothing happens and
it's kind of a cool little moment
because what is up happening is of
course they basically end up merging
into the ultra monitor basically this
gigantic monitor unto itself like the
single ultra powerful beam that was one
of the forces are really kind of the
total force that ended up defeating
Perpetua in the first place but all
indications seem to point to the idea
that perpetuates power is either a p--
or a little bit higher than it was when
they originally fun and so she can't
really be defeated in the traditional
sense instead it's going to require more
ability than what was originally had in
order to see her defeated and so jumping
back to the past with regards to the
Justice League fighting alongside the
JSA their journey to find the totality
after essentially stopping the Legion of
Doom to a degree with regard to the
attack on Pearl Harbor is that what the
Legion of Doom appears to be
incapacitated their journey ends up
taking them to Atlantis and of course
this kind of coincides with the time in
which Atlantis is king is basically
missing and so ultimately the Legion of
Doom makes their move only to reveal
that they've captured Poseidon and it's
kind of a funny thing here because when
that happens at the same time that takes
place you end up getting Vandal Savage
and as Legionnaires Club now Vandal
Savage and Legionnaires Club is a group
that we've seen in the early stories of
Scott Steiners run on Justice League
there were after the totality and
managed to capture a portion of it and
so what this looks like and I'm not
going to swear to this as an absolute
truth but what this looks like is the
absolute past of the DC Universe this is
actually the past right so basically
they've they've gone into 1945 in the
past the main DC Universe being the
Justice Society of America existed
during that point in time which begs the
question why don't they exist now again
tying back into the events of Doomsday
Clock it's a cool little bit of a
revelation here but where you have the
where you have Brainiac 1 million who's
basically going off against the the
Justice League the Justice League
doesn't really seem to be able to defeat
it just because of the fact that
Brainiac 1 million is so incredibly
powerful well you've got the Justice
League in the present day who weren't
really able to do anything to stop
Perpetua and then you've got the
Legionnaires Club basically showing up
in the past
all really points of the idea the
caffeine totalities even if they can do
it won't fix everything but it doesn't
look like they can it is not looking
they can actually capture the pieces of
the totality and save everything so what
it does is it all falls down on the
shoulders of commanding and Kimani
begins the dressing basically this this
particular group out there this unseen
you know group out there and says like
we need more people here right like we
need more help the Justice League as it
exists now is not powerful enough on
their own
we need more forces here and that's what
we end up finding out the command ease
not just talking to anybody
command ease actually talking to the
Justice League Unlimited group talking
to like Batman unlimited Superman
unlimited all these characters DC's
taking the unlimited universe or at
least Scott Snyder is and rolling it
into the Justice League comics this is
amazing but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come as explained
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you while later
first I want to give a shout out to
Jason see Austin s Jason s Austin H
Phillip and Austin B we have one of
Austin's and our patreon as well as G
gnosis 916 de gnosis didn't give us a
first and last name so we kind of had to
go with it I didn't mention your last
names but I want to say thank you to you
all by the way your rob for rings should
be on their way for our honor guard
members of the Rob core for these
special patrons your custom rob pour
rings should be on their way they're
being shipped to me after that I will
have them shipped to you stay tuned keep
your eye on patreon in your messages and
you will hear about them coming to you
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]